hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
exosome Amara mi RNA sequencing for
biomarker profiling using the ion s5
system and ion total RNA seek kit
presented by dr. Leslie Chang
postdoctoral researcher I'm Christina
jewel of lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by thermo Fisher Scientific
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also we will be
conducting a few audience polls the poll
will pop up on your screen and we
appreciate your participation our first
poll of the day which RNA application
would you like to learn more about
select all that apply
whole transcriptome RNA sequencing
targeted RNA sequencing for
transcriptome analysis targeted RNA
sequencing for selected gene expression
analysis small RNA sequencing non-coding
RNA sequencing fusion gene detection or
none of the above also please notice
that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located in the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and the software's
continuing education credits
please click on the button at the top at
the bottom left corner and follow the
process to obtain your credits
I'd now like to introduce our presenter
dr. Leslie Chang is a postdoctoral
researcher she was awarded a Bachelor of
medical science with honors and a PhD
from Monash University Australia
she is currently based at Latrobe
Institute for molecular science Latrobe
University Australia her research
expertise combines basic and clinical
science through the use of novel cell
and molecular biology approaches to
identify biomarker candidates for
diagnostic testing currently her major
focus is to develop a minimally invasive
blood test for the early detection of
monitor early detection and monitoring
of neurodegenerative diseases such as
Alzheimer's disease Parkinson's disease
and prion disease her research involves
detecting disease signatures of RNA
molecules called micro RNA which can be
collected from small biological vesicles
called exosomes that travel in the Bret
bloodstream
she is also investigating the functional
role of exosomes in neurodegenerative
diseases as they have been found to
cause the spread of disease in the body
I would like to turn the presentation
over to dr. Cheng hi everyone thanks for
joining us today on this webinar I'm
assuming that if you are here on today
that you're interested in performing
small RNA sequencing on the Ion Torrent
platform and perhaps you will also be
profiling x's own so a lot of my
research does focus on X's own they are
an extra cellular membrane vesicle of
endosomal origin as you can see from
this VM image they are about 50 to 100
nanometers in diameter they carry
nucleic acids proteins and lipids you
can see from this by analyzer profile
that your main to exosomes contain an
enriched population of micro RNA tRNA
and small RNA and this is quite
different to what we see in
cells which is in lien one of the by
analyzer profiles they also contain
protein and as you can see in this flame
that the exosomes protein lettering is
quite different to wholesale they see
one of the RNA species that I am mostly
interested in in my research is micro
RNA and they are a non-coding small RNA
species packaged in 2x azumed so micro
RNA are transcribed in nucleus as
primary micro RNA of several several
thousand nucleotides long it is then
further processed by an RNA s3 type of
enzyme Tricia - precursor micro RNA
before being transported from the
nucleus to the cytosol via export in one
from here in the cytosol is further
cleaved by by such a producer and micro
RNA micro RNA duplex of about 22
nucleotides mom where one strand is then
incorporated into the RNA induced
silencing complex together with our go
to from here micro RNA can then be
bounced to the target messenger RNA and
inhibit translation of the protein from
here Micro and they can also be bound to
RNA binding protein and be secreted into
the bloodstream
they can also be packaged into X's own
and then be secreted into the
bloodstream
from here the blood strip from here in
the bloodstream
exosomes can then be taken up by a
recipient cell where it's micro RNA
content can influence translation in the
recipient cell however as we know we can
collect blood and then isolate exosomes
from the blood and so now X events have
been used as a major source of
biomarkers and potentially and contain a
diagnostic indicators for various
diseases such as cancer infectious
diseases and brain diseases however when
you collect blood micro RNA can be found
in various
components of the blood such as in the
neat serum or plasma or in the cellular
component which contains red blood cells
or white blood cells etc so when
profiling for micro RNA in blood it
would be important to find out where the
strongest disease signature lies in
terms of the cell free plasma you can
find micro RNA bound to RNA binding
proteins or contained in exosomes in the
cellular component they can also
originate from the red blood cells or
white blood cells so some of my work
back in 2014
involved trying to understand where the
majority of micro RNA may be useful when
it comes to diagnostic testing or
biomarker discovery so what I did was
collect whole blood and isolated for
intracellular RNA using package entry I
also fascinated the whole blood to
collect for cell free serum and plasma
where with the cell free serum and
plasma I performed a sequential ultra
centrifugation to isolate X's own in
order to isolate then the RNA from the
exposome palate I use the mi RNA easy
kit I compare these ultracentrifuge
episomal RNA profiles with a commercial
kit from morgan biotech as well as
comparing these profiles to a self cell
free or neat plasma or serum this was
all collected from healthy volunteers so
running these samples on the buy
analyzer using a small RNA chip you can
see in the packs genes firstly that
packaging RNA shows tRNA and 5s RNA as
well as micro RNA not surprisingly when
you treat the PAX gene RNA with RNAs a
this is all degraded when you look at
cell free plasma and serum you can see
that cell free plasma and zero contains
mostly micro RNA and slightly the
of other small RNA not surprisingly
again when you do an ons a treatment all
the RNA in plasma or serum is also
degraded so what happens when we use
exosomes samples looking at the exosome
or RNA that were isolated by the
ultracentrifuge you can see with plasma
and serum they contain the majority of
micro RNA and other small RNA and when
you treat these samples with RNA you can
see that the RNA is no longer degraded
and potentially protected by the lipid
membrane of exposome looking at the
commercial kit by an origin biotech the
same profile is quite similar in serum
and it's also quite similar in plasma
however in this by analyzer trace I've
shown you an example of what happens
when there is intracellular
contamination and upon RNAs a treatment
you can see the degradation that's
happening there as the overall exosomes
contain a small component and rich
population of small RNA in particular
micro RNA that is protected from RN aids
treatment and in the bloodstream there
is a high volume of rnases floating in
the bloodstream making exosomes
ideal for biomarker discovery so if I'm
performing small RNA sequencing on the
samples you can see on the y-axis at
where I've graphed the percentage of
matched ribs looking for micro RNAs no
RNA ribosomal RNA and other non-coding
RNA that exercise contain the highest
percentage of micro RNA from 31 percent
to 48 percent this is in comparison to
when you look at neck serum or plasma
where you get about 13 to 14 percent
micro RNA and patched in tubes 28
percent micro RNA so essentially by
isolating exosomes
you could potentially improve
signal-to-noise ratio for diagnostic
testing or biomarker discovery so the
website that I use is outlined in this
slide
firstly I perform sample collection
today I will be mostly focusing on
plasma and serum however of course you
can collect
exosomes from traditions our culture
supernatant
and I'll show you a bit play so that
we've also been able to isolate extra
zones term intact tissues such as the
brain and the with endo and perform
exosome isolation if that is what you
are interested in profiling exosome all
you can extract RNA after this I
followed by an RNA quality assessment
and their construction of the small RNA
libraries followed by ion torrent
sequencing which takes about two and a
half hours for run this is followed then
by QC using various QC program for your
NGS analysis and then followed by
bioinformatics analysis so the ion
torrent s5 chip that I mostly use is the
540 chip where you're able to obtain 60
to 80 million ring
most of my libraries are between 22 to
200 nucleotides in length and this
mostly comprises of the small RNA family
members of the small RNA family of
course there are non-coding RNA as
opposed to coding RNA so the small RNA
family consists of no RNA pili oweneen
micro RNA which are 18 to 25 nucleotides
in length
si RNA and more nucleolar RNA all these
small RNAs
play a crucial role in the regulation of
gene and they control a diverse number
of cellular and biological pathways
currently there's about 2,500 known
micro RNA species in the human and
approximately the same in the mice as
well so our lab has really been in the
forefront of easy field
from characterizing exosomes and then
followed by being able to profile
exercises and this really all began in
2007 and eight we were able to
characterize X's ohms isolated from CSF
as well as exercise from various cell
lines such as those that are infected
with the prion protein and also our
Alzheimer's disease cell models where we
identified the presence of the prion
protein and fragments of a 15 episode in
2012 were able to show the first cryo-em
of prion infected cells as well as being
able to sequence micro RNA from these
prion infected cells using back then the
solid platform in 2013 we found that xsm
like vesicles were responsible for cell
to cell communication in malaria
infected red blood cells in 2014 our
first papers using the I inherent
systems were published where I was able
to profile blue RNA in an extensive and
comprehensive way from exercise isolated
from various biological fluids such as
urine plasma and serum in 2015 I
published a paper where I applied this
workflow to sample serum samples
collected from Alzheimer's disease
patients where I was able to identify a
panel of micro RNA biomarkers associated
with Alzheimer's disease as well as
melanoma in 2006 we started publishing
on how we believe the prion protein is
packaged into exosomes
and in 2007 this year we've also
published a number of papers using the
inspi so our lab has also been part of
many tools in development that can be
accessed online such as databases that
create the a database of what proteins
and micro RNA or RNA species are found
in excessive
shows vesicle PDA EVP easy track and
there are online as well so in terms of
X's own isolation we typically use
sequential ultracentrifugation which is
really a universal tool so in this slide
I've demonstrated condition medium but
you can also obviously use plasma or
serum where we perform a 2000 GSM two
pallets LG breeze we'd then transfer the
supernatant to a ultracentrifuge where
we then been at 10,000 GS to pellet
large moles large multi vesicles the
trap is super need is then transferred
again to be spun at 100,000 G's to
pellet exosomes further by a PBS wash to
wash the palliative exosome and to be
spun at a hundred thousand genes at the
end you get a pallet of exercise and you
can characterize the exosomes via
western blotting are looking at exosome
or markers such as TSG 101 slots limb
and non exosome or markers such as bcl-2
which which represents a product body's
goal ggm 130 and nuclear port poram
which is nuclei typically we also view
our X's own preparation by electron
microscopy and using the sequential
ultra centrifugation protocol it usually
consists of a crude isolation where
sometimes you get other vehicle sizes
and sometimes some protein contamination
as well so you can then take this
exosome palette and perform a of the
protoss olicity gradients to further
purify inspection at your extra zooms
using a 10 to 30% object gradient you
floats your X's on pallets on top of
this gradient where you can then upon a
250,000 G spin collect fractions and
then perform a Western blot to determine
which fraction your is so slow to that
so in this western blot you can see the
extra zones are positive for th g 101
and 36 history
infraction eight to nine and you can see
in the e/m that these pepper ratios are
a lot more pure so in terms of biomarker
discovery we wanted to determine whether
it was necessary to perform a octave
prep velocity gradient with exosomes and
we sequenced the fraction eight and nine
from the object prep radius as well as
preparations of exosomes isolated by the
crude method which is just an
ultracentrifuge preparation and we
compared these two fractions on either
side fraction seven and a as well as
cells and you can see that a fraction
eight and nine as long and the
ultracentrifuge episomes clustered
together suggesting that there has
similar more RNA profiles in this Venn
diagram the common micro RNA species
there's the majority of micro RNA
species are also the same between an
ultra centrifugation prep and also a
fraction am I suggesting that it's
probably unnecessary to further purify
exosomes for biomarker discovery and
that ultra centrifugation is this may be
good enough to obtain the same small RNA
profiles for biomarker discovery so what
we've also done is translated protocol
which is very similar to isolate serum
and plasma exposome as you can see that
and they also a positive for floss alone
transference
we've also here a pro for PRP as we've
seen the prion protein present in
exosomes as well as series six history
these are X's ohms from plasma serum
under a.m. and using nano site particle
counter they are all of fitting in about
100 nanometers in size what we've also
been able to do in our lab is not only
isolate exosomes from say what we call
circulating exosomes
but also from intact brain tissue and so
this protocol has been published this
year in Jeff the Journal of
extracellular vesicles
we've been able to float the exercise on
a triple super cushion after being able
to loosely remove the exosomes gently
from the intact tissue perform a series
of ultracentrifuge in floated on a
triple sucrose cushion and upon
characterization we have found that the
x's ohms are floating infraction -
before all of the brain derived X's own
work and we are we're investigating
exosomes
infraction - of course
ultracentrifugation can take a while and
we've also explored the use of
commercial exosome RNA tips such as the
nauseam clip which I spoke about
previously but also the kids through
Invitrogen and thermo such as the ones
that isolate as my own serum as well as
them the vannacutt so going through the
my workflow for NGA and initially once
you have isolated your exercise or
samples we perform a small RNA quality
assessment using the by analyzer and
this typically have looks like most what
you can see on the slide it's much more
easier to make small RNA libraries
obviously from cells or tissue and in
this case where you have not only
smaller a neighbor also a messenger RNA
we perform a RNAs 6000 SA and does this
is just to look to see whether the RNA
is of good quality and anything greater
than a rim of seven is usable for NGS so
you can see here that this particular
sample from brain tissue has a ring of
ten which is great I has a percentage of
small RNA as well as messenger RNA and
potentially in long non-coding RNA when
you then go and look at the small RNA
profile you can see a peak of T RNA
ribosomal RNA
so with these sort of samples what I do
with the small RNAs a is determine what
is the percentage of micro RNA and this
percentage of micro RNA will give you an
indication of how successful your small
RNA libraries will be so this particular
sample is 22% after enrichment and even
if the small RNA percentage is quite low
it is necessary I believe to perform a
small RNA in which meant before
continuing on to smaller any
construction as ideally you want to
remove as much messenger RNA out of the
system before attaching your adapters so
another way where your samples can be
enriched with small RNA and not having
to enrich it in the lab is basically
looking at X's own samples so as I saw
as I presented before serum exosomes
usually are already biologically
enriched with small RNA the small
Iranian enrichment is not required and
you can see in this particular profile
that there is a lot of micro RNA already
so this is quite different and ideally
we do need a minimum of more than one
nanogram per microliter of more RNA this
is quite different to for example the
small RNA profile from exosomes from
conditioned media sometimes they are not
in which with small RNA and they can
also contain tear tRNA but this is okay
usually they don't contain anything
larger than 200 nucleotides so you don't
need to perform a small RNA enrichment
and then go ahead with your adapter
ligation in terms of when you isolate
exosomes
and you're not using a commercial kit
that goes from exposome straight to RNA
I do isolate the exercise from
ultracentrifugation protocol and then
use trys LLS to extract my RNA which
will serve it very well so then when it
comes to small RNA library construction
I use the iron turns high in total RNA
stick version to library this is the
workflow of the protocol which I'll
briefly go through my library quality
control and assessment this protocol has
also been published in methods and
protocols if you want to have a look
this basically involves some of my
tricks and also several changes to the
mode to a protocol to be able to make
small RNA libraries from more yields of
RNA in particular from episode so as I
mentioned it's quite straightforward to
make small RNA libraries when you have
plentiful of RNA such as in brain tissue
or cells so what we do here is determine
the percentage of divided RNA ligated
product from the total ligated products
so the bar codes themselves and adapt is
the 5-prime adapter and the 3-prime
adapter are usually about 85 base pairs
in length alone if you are by coding
your libraries so with if there is no
insert you will see that you'll have a
peak on your DNA 1000s a chip at 85 base
pairs 1 if you have a 10 Baystate insert
that means your inserts or your like
data products would be about 95 based
tests and then if you do have a micro
RNA insert your fragments should be
sitting at about 105 base pairs long
anything larger will be about 135 base
pairs long and greater so you can see in
my by analyze the traits here that I
have a number of peak and this
109 peak is mostly could be micro RNA
and then other small RNA species so when
you perform a small RNA as mere a smear
test what I do is skate to the entire
library 50 to 300 and then also gates
what I'm actually interested in which is
anything beyond mining one base test
which will have an insert and then to
250 and so the the fragments that I'm
interested in
takes up 94 percent of my library here
which is great so we basically aim for
anything greater than 50 percent of the
desired ligated products anything
greater than 50 will tend to produce a
good sequencing run but obviously the
more the better so the difficult thing
is when you start having lower RNA
yields to play with which here we've got
50 nano grams of RNA and the profile
here you can see a small peak of primer
dimers appearing where and there is no
insert but overall we have 72 percent of
desired ligated products which which
still works in this case in terms of
when you are making smaller in our
libraries from X's own we rarely have
heaps of RNA and in this case we have
one milligram of RNA so what happens
with one nanogram RNA the barcode and
the adapters are basically in excess of
what the RNA is of the RNA that is
contained in the tube so upon cleaning
your adapters and barcodes we see that
sometimes there is a high percentage of
primer dimers and so this is one of the
major issues when we construct my RNA
libraries with low RNA yield and you can
see here that the smear test only
produced 48 percent of the desired like
a
of products so what I basically do is in
terms of when you're using pressure
samples you may have no choice but to
accept these primer diamonds and filter
them out during bioinformatics analysis
or you can try and size select and clean
again however I find that you end up
losing a lot more than gaining of course
you can always try and increase only
input but when it comes to using
biological samples or post-mortem tissue
obviously those patients ample for quite
pressure and you may not have enough to
begin with so what I do with their
samples now is basically upon RNA
extraction
I then speedy of a crime file all you
Mon RNA and use it all in terms of the
overnight that's in terms of the adapter
ligation I perform my overnight
incubation 16 degrees for 16 hours and I
find this greatly improve the success of
the small RNA library construction I
also decrease the amount of adapters I
put in at the very beginning and in
terms of size selection and using
ethanol I find that exceptional
preparing works very well make sure that
your pipette are calibrated and that you
are preparing correctly the volume of
ethanol and what you will get hopefully
is very clean libraries from one
nanogram of RNA so those are my tips of
constructing small RNA from Luud samples
what we've also been managed to do in
our lab is also semi orbit automate
small RNA library using the biomech 4000
as well so this has helped a lot with
our workflow when we've got many samples
after this I then of course move my
samples and libraries to the iron chest
and this instrument has really been
great you know lab and being able to
give us a lot of reproducibility in
terms of our
from here on in terms of the library
construction a concentration on the iron
chef's I use 45 picker molar where I
find that this gives us the best
sequencing results to run the eye ns5
it's quite simple what I do is always
set up a template run where we have our
own template protocol on our system here
you can see I've called it a hill that's
more RNA template and basically is quite
good friendly to use and then you can
just to your runs ready for sequencing
the next day here is one of our
completed runs so you can see here that
this run showed minus t minus 3% loading
on the chip and the usable reads
we've reached quite close to capacity
which is 7m my minion reads and you can
see the breakdown of each sample that
was bar coded on the chip which were
which reaches about four to five memory
per sample in terms of the concentration
that are used for template preparation
on the iron chef 45 picomolar
we're sitting at 34% polyclonal which is
usually ideal in terms of template's
dilution and we've got 56 statistics
percent clonal and then all the
sweltering gives us the 80 million reads
ready for by informatics analysis this
particular samples the average read
length is about 100 nucleotides long for
these samples and similar in air
libraries so this works well what I've
done is applied this to some of our
research involving our famous disease
Alzheimer's disease is characterized by
the buildup of a neurotoxic protein
called amyloid beta and this buildup of
this protein causes neuronal cell death
and impairment in thinking and
memory the average onset of this disease
is sixty-five years old as illustrated
in this graph however we now know that
the build-up of amyloid actually occurs
10 years before the onset of symptoms as
you can see here so if you were
diagnosed at 65 years old the build-up
of amyloid may have occurred when you
were 55 years old
the treatments aimed at limiting the
build-up of amyloid beta really requires
a method to diagnose the disease earlier
and so that we can monitor the disease
earlier and potentially administer any
drugs prior to the build-up of a greater
load of amyloid beta a lot of our work
each participant is had imaged and you
can see in this figure the build-up of
amyloid beta in the brain as indicated
by the fluorescence and in this patch
image which is compared to the lack of
the build-up of an amyloid tracer in a
healthy control brain the idea here is
that although PET imaging is a quite
accurate it's not ideal for routine
testing and our lab has been focused on
developing a blood test which is less
invasive it's more convenient and it's
also cost effective as well so we
collect our samples from a from a cohort
in Australia called able the Stirling
imaging biomarkers and lifestyle study
of aging it was launched in 2006 it's
one of the longest largest more maternal
study of its kind in Australia
it contains currently 1600 participants
where the minimum age is about 60 years
old
we have Alzheimer's disease patients
those with mild cognitive impairment
disorder and also controls and every
participant undergoes a battery of
assessment
every 18 months where they come in and
form neuropsychological test they get
pet imaged and we also collects their
blood as well so back in 2015 I
published a paper where we were able to
apply this small only workflow through a
number of patients with Alzheimer's
disease and her and also with the
healthy controls and I found a panel of
16 micro RNAs that were significantly
deregulated in the ad so this this
comprised are two major clusters
thirteen micro rna's which were
upregulated and three which were down
arugula and using random forest modeling
we were able to show that this panel of
micro RNA was able to predict for ad as
with high accuracy as well as
sensitivity and specificity here are the
16 exosome or my current RNA biomarkers
as you can see in the red that some are
upregulated in the 80s and others are
down regulated in terms of sensitivity
and specificity were able to attain 87%
sensitivity as well as feminist and
specificity what we've now moved on to
do is to see whether those 16 16 micro
RNA my micro RNA will also also
differentially expressed in the brains
of post-mortem tissue of AD patients so
here you can see that we've been able to
compare post-mortem tissue from control
samples and enter 8 as well as those
from ad patients or subjects we were
able to isolate grand jurors exosomes
from these tissues and what I also did
was also look at the profiles from home
brain tissues as well what I wanted to
look at is whether there was any
differentially expressed in micro RNA
in this ad Branch Road exit zones and
also in the whole brain and compare them
to the data set that I previously
sequence using the serum exosomes
and looking what we wanted to do was see
whether there is any common
differentially expressed micro RNA
between the brain as well as the serum
in order to potentially develop a liquid
biopsy of the brain that represented
more closely to what was happening in
the brain initially what we wanted to
see whether there was any small RNA and
micro RNA in these brain derived
exosomes as well as whole brain and you
can see this was from our post-mortem
tissue from healthy subjects refraction
- as approval approval shows where the
brain derived extra zooms are found and
you can see that 74% of micro RNA I
found in fraction - which is the brand
to row vector zoom
whereas in whole tissue there is 12%
micro RNA so from here we then sequenced
the branch arrays extra zooms as well as
whole brain from a post-mortem tissue of
AD subjects as well as healthy controls
and I compared this more RNA profiles to
serum exosome profiles that a previously
sequenced so this graph basically allows
me to determine what common micro RNA
species are found in the brain and serum
on the y axis I have grasped the fold
changes found in whole brain tissue ad
versus healthy control world two fold
change where the bottom of this graph
you can see basically are all the micro
RNA species and that are down regulated
and on this side of the graph are those
that are all up regulated in the x axis
I have grasped the brain derived extra
zone of ad versa
is healthy control on this side of the
graph are those that are done regulated
and on this side of the graph they're
all the ones that are upregulated hence
in this quadrant these microRNAs for
example up regulated in the whole brain
but down regulated in the brain derived
let's assume they are of opposite
expression whereas in this quadrant they
are within the same direction and being
upregulated in both sample types so
essentially in terms of picking up a
biomarker in both tissues ideally using
qPCR the second quadrant here would be
ideal to pick up being upregulated in
both tissues what I also did was grasp
also the micro RNA that were found in
serum exosomes versus the brand derived
exposome to determine whether there is
any common micro RNA species in the
serum where I could pick them up as a
diagnostic indicator that is reflective
of what is happening in the brain so
would be this quadrant here
interestingly some of these micro RNA
that were identified in these studies
are predicted to hit messenger RNA
targets associated with alzheimer's
disease such as a PP processing aquatic
cell death as well as ER stress and
pathway involving GF k3b
as well as the NMDA receptor this is
using tiger skin and also KEGG pathway
analysis part of our lab we've also been
able to develop tools to analyze normal
RNA in particular wrong file generated
by the Ion Torrent which you which is
currently available from this link here
so overall today hopefully I've shown
you
that accidents provide a protective
environment for RNA code cargo as seen
in the first slides looking at by
analyzer profiles from X's own samples
and treated with ponies a accidents can
be isolated from biological fluids and
are enriched with micro RNA isolation
method should cater for high-throughput
biomarker screening so it's best to try
and optimize your RNA isolation and
increase RNA yield before going into
small RNA library construction so tips
for improving exosome or more RNA
libraries is basically to maximize
exosome yield
through the various isolation methods
you can use to isolate the exosome
followed by maximizing RNA extraction
exploring various RNA kits and then
followed by concentrating the RNA using
a speedy vac if you don't have enough
RNA to begin with you can speed of a kit
or and then use the entire volume for
more RNA library construction overnight
ligation reaction definitely helps a lot
and decreasing the adapter input at the
beginning you can also increase PCR
cycles during the PCR amplification I
wouldn't do more than 1820 cycles
through and then you can compare the
small RNA profile with the resultant
library proof profile so looking at your
RNA profile and determining how
successful you will be at the very end
upon library assessment in terms of
selecting biomarker candidates
so once you've already run your samples
through the s5 or the Ion Torrent you
can have a look at what sort of reads
you rotate and after some experience
you'll see that sample collection
does affect your by automatic analysis a
lot and so careful sample collection is
very important experimental design is
also very important and then filtering
for abundant species for analysis to
remove biological variability
I always check the route royal reads
between the normalized read before
validation by qPCR this is to ensure
that you are trying to validate the most
abundant species that have appeared in
your NGS data and also a great tip is to
use your NGS data to find endogenous
controls for normalization when it comes
to to PCR validation so this is our lab
here and put all the people that are
involved in this work or all highlighted
here our lab is funded by various
funding agencies as well as government
agencies so that is it for my
presentation and we will now go to some
questions Thank You dr. chang for that
informative presentation as you said we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
our webinar if you have any questions
you would like to ask please do so now
just click on the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window type your question in the box
that appears on the screen and click the
send button we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for if by
chance we run out of time before we have
answered your question
dr. Chang will follow up via email
following the presentation okay let's
get started our first question is ok dr.
Chang what are your thoughts on EXO
quick vs. UC I think the it's a quick
product when it first came out we were
really unsure on the level of
contamination that was produced by the
exit protocol since then I think they've
greatly improved from characterizing the
exosomes that do that are produced from
that if they click reagent we
see several sizes of vesicles so it's
it's probably a lot more difference to
ultra certification but I think if you
use XO quick as long as you get
reproducible results and potentially
looking just for a biomarker and process
all your samples by exact week it's high
and what we did was compare the profiles
of ultra certifications to commercial
kits such as if they're quick and then
picked the kit the commercial kits that
produce the closest profile to
ultracentrifuge obviously for biomarker
discovery you want to be able to isolate
X deserves as fast as you can
diagnostic labs really don't have time
for ultra centrifuge protocol so in
terms of X so quick the profiles do look
a little bit different but as long as
you remain consistent you can use it for
biomarker discovery that's a great one
have you used enriched to small RNA from
breast cancer cells in terms of the
exercises that are secreted or just the
cells
oh I'm assuming maybe just the cells we
haven't done it on breast cancer cells
but it wouldn't be too different from
sequencing small RNA from any other type
of cell line so what I would do is
isolate the RNA from your cell line
being in this case breast cancer cells
performing making sure the Rin looks
good and then performing an RNA
enrichment so these days when I am
making small RNA libraries from cells I
perform at a small RNA enrichment no
matter what just to increase the chances
of the adapters binding to only small
RNA and
we um first question what does the
filter point 22 micrometers mean sorry
that is the filters that we use to
filter our conditions super mean it to
remove any larger vesicles that may be
present so before carrying forward to
the ultracentrifugation spins we filter
our conditioned supernatant with a point
to 2 micron filter we also filter all of
our buses with the point to 2 micron
filter to ensure that there's no
vesicles from other sources that may be
present and this is particularly
important when we're reading when we're
using a particle counter such as the
mana side or two nano dr. Chang on your
run report what are the millions of
reads that have no barcode those are the
reads that barcode were not detected or
the s5 current server was unable to
determine so it gets filtered out as a
mobile code read and then placed into
another file we have an audience member
John who would like to know why do you
have bimodal read lengths and high
average read lengths on the previous
slide are you not filtering out larger
sequencing sequences so in terms of the
high average read length so 55 base
pairs Scot which slide that was on so no
we're not filtering any larger sequences
greater than the micro RNA so although
I'm interested in micro know firstly I
will sequence
I will map to micro RNA or near base
first so that would be looking at the 22
nucleotide Freeman length and then what
I do is with the other
a longer read links such as 55 base
pairs etc I will then map the map them
to for example Ensemble and then
determine whether any of those other
longer red legs other types of mälaren
air bio types and that really carries
into just other additional analysis see
whether we find for example tRNA or snow
RNA exit share for further investigative
information time also is asking also
what were the large number of no barcode
samples have you performed additional
analyses on those no I haven't actually
but I believe these may be fragments the
way by the by code was not ligated into
the fragments so sometimes there will be
you know a certain percentage always and
whether this is high or low is dependent
on the run itself
dr. Chang have you ever compared the mi
RNA profiles between serum and plasma
yes if you go back to the beginning of
my presentation or just see if I can do
that I did publish this work and when I
compared serum and plasma in Jeff if you
want to look that up so that slide here
is 0 and plasma so this is looking at
Nate's serum and plasma where you can
see the differences between our small
RNA profile in terms of the small RNA
profiles that are sequenced and they can
be sometimes slightly different and you
can look that up in this paper chang at
LG of 2014
okay how about
have you use other library preparation
methods that employee adapters that
decrease overall adapter dimmers via
chemical modifications for example try
link no I haven't tried it ideally what
we want to do is to obviously minimize
primer adapters today I've shown you
some of my tips at the end ideally yes
we do want to develop a kit that will
reduce primer dimers fortunately is
quite difficult when and some of our
samples will only have one nanogram of
RNA available for us to mix more in a
library
dr. Chang have you looked at a my RNA
presence within microvesicles as well is
there a reason you have focused
specifically on exosomes the a good
question we have Pro fold small RNA from
microvesicles as well as a pop tonic
bodies and again they produce a
different more RNA profile where there
is less micro RNA in micro vesicles and
a product bodies so if you look at some
of the papers that I've shown here we
have isolated and sequence microvesicles
in this paper published in RNA biology
which I'll point to here as well as in
this year we also published another one
more recently again macand microvesicles
and apoptotic bodies depending on this
depending on the cell line and these
various vesicles will produce different
percentages of small RNA species and so
you can have a look at these
publications and look at the breakdown
of small RNA bio types in various and
cell lines in basic course as well
dr. Chang Jolin from the University of
Calgary would like to know is the
process of PBS washing necessary in
ultracentrifugation yeah it depends on
what you want to do with your ex's owns
later so I find that for some samples
washing performing their PBS wash you
may end up losing a lot more exosomes
than gaining if you want to perform
functional assays with your ex's own
talent I think it is important to wash
your exes ohms with PBS and then spin
them again we find with the biomarker
work if you if there is any protein
contamination it will be removed during
the RNA extraction and so the PBS wash
isn't it as important how much serum is
required for a my RNA analysis for NGS
sequencing if you are isolating exosomes
from serum and plasma I usually need a
minimum of one meal for after the
validation after the NGS process and you
want to just do the validation by to PCR
I usually use anything between 300 to
500 microliters of serum and plasma
followed by the exosome extraction
method
you
sorry about that um do we have time for
just a few more questions um have you
compared EVM I RNA profile versus
circulating mi RNA profile in serum yes
I have I have compared both between the
DV profiles and the NEET profile again
this was published in this paper here in
Jeb in 2014 where I compared the
profiles from both serum and plasma
[Music]
isolated from you from exercise isolated
by the ultracentrifuge as well as a
commercial kit from origin and I
compared these profiles to NEET profiles
from plasma in serum so you can have a
look at that profile as well so that
publication
thank you dr. Cheng and we will close
with this last question what methods are
there to isolate exosomes for diagnostic
testing the depending on what you want
to do there's several methods that you
can use the ultra centrifugation
protocol various commercial kits that
are currently now on the market and
there's many of them and I suggest that
you try them all to see whether in your
hands you can isolate enough RNA from
your serum and plasma volume and that
whether that amount works for library
construction thank you again dr. Cheng
and thank you for your important
research do you have any final comments
for audience now all the best with the
your sequencing project I would like to
once again thank dr. Cheng for her
presentation and I would also like to
thank laberd's and Thermo Fisher
Scientific for making today's
educational webcast possible now before
we go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May 2
thousand 18 you will receive an email
from lab roots letting you know when
this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
and thank you for joining us we hope to
see you again soon goodbye